Das sieht aber nicht aus wie CSI.
Nee, nicht.
... Interview heute mit Ihnen.
Wow. Krass, ne Frau.
Brille noch mal ab!
Noch mal auf!
Noch mal ab!
Ohne sieht halt schöner aus!
Das ist alles
nicht sicherheitskonform.
Können wir für den Opening Shot
die Brille mal so ....
... denkermmäßig in den Mund nehmen?
Man kann nicht die Schutzbrille
in den Mund nehmen. Das geht nicht.
Das hat aber nichts
mit meiner Arbeit zu tun.
Können Sie
eine Denkerpose einnehmen?
Eine bitte was?
- Eine Denkerpose.
Und dann nach oben nehmen und ganz
wissenshungrig durchgucken
und schütteln dabei.
Ja, das ist es! Das ist super!
Sind Sie sicher, dass der Kolben
im Trockenschrank stehen soll?
Das macht man normalerweise nicht.
Fangen Sie doch einfach an, ganz
frei von Ihrer Therapie zu erzählen.
Also, ich arbeite in dem Bereich
drug delivery.
Das ist relevant
in der Krebsforschung z.B.
Da es ja durchaus Medikamente gibt,
die für bestimmte Krebsarten
wirksam sind, aber ...
Das ist direkt schon sehr
kompliziert, viel zu unnötig.
Werden Sie denn mit der Therapie
den Nobelpreis gewinnen?
Den Nobelpreis?
Ja, Kartoffel, potato ...
Wir ... der Nobelpreis wird ja
normalerweise verlieren an ...
... Lebenswerke,
auch von Wissenschaftlern.
Wir sind jetzt eben ...
Also würde die Therapie auch
gar nicht nach Ihnen benannt?
Die ... Ich ...
Okay, dann sagen Sie
doch am besten einfach mal:
Wir werden mit dieser neuen Therapie
den Krebs in fünf Jahren besiegen.
Das kann ich nicht sagen!
Das ist einfach nicht akkurat.
Man kann das normalerweise
auch nie so genau ...
Wo ist denn die Formel?
- Die Formel? - Ja!
Die Formel ...
Jau, Matze, ich glaub,
das haben wir dann.
Also ich hab nichts mehr. - Nee.
Da kriegst du keine Story raus.
Das guckt sich keiner an.
Wir müssen gleich weiter.
Wir haben noch den
Top-Ten-Wasserrutschen-Test.
Wir machen ganz schnell
ein anderes Thema durch.
Wie ist es denn mit Glyphosat?
(Sie reden konfus durcheinander)
Können wir direkt
Crystal Meth kochen?
(Sie reden konfus durcheinander)
Oder Ihre Meinung zu Gender Studies
Männer, Frauen ...
(Sie reden konfus durcheinander)
Bitcoins!
(schreit) Ich bin Chemikerin!!
Alle 11 Minuten wird Wissenschaft
von den Medien falsch dargestellt.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob die Statistik so stimmt ...
Hi, ich heiße Mai, ich bin Chemikerin
und YouTuberin.
Wenn ihr Wissenschaft haben wollt,
die unterhaltsam und korrekt ist,
dann müsst ihr maiLab abonnieren.
Denn hier sind die Wissenschaftler
nicht nur vor,
sondern auch hinter der Kamera!
Diejenigen, die mir bei Instagram
folgen, wissen es wohl schon:
Ich bin demnächst
wirklich bald im Fernsehen, Freunde.
Und zwar bei Quarks!
Das ist so cool, weil ich Quarks und
Co auch immer selbst geschaut habe.
Also "Quarks" heißt das nur noch.
Es ist der perfekte Beweis dafür,
dass Wissenschaft
im Fernsehen doch funktioniert.
Falls ihr es noch nicht seht, kann
ich es jetzt wärmstens empfehlen.
Wenn ihr nichts verpassen wollt,
folgt mir auf Instagram.
Zusammen mit einem maiLab-Abo
seid ihr da noch bestens ausgerüstet.
Wir sehen uns Donnerstag, Freunde
der Sonne. Bis dahin. Bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk